before there was all of this
[Music]
what's this
what then Netflix changed everything
once a DVD distributor it's easy
became a streaming Pioneer
revolutionizing the way people watch TV
and movies other networks and Studios
raced to catch up and now Disney HBO and
NBC are chipping away at Netflix's
market and in April 2022 report from
Netflix saying it's lost subscribers for
the first time in a decade that was
enough to send it stock plummeting 35
percent in a single day Netflix's worst
day since 2004 and though the stock
hasn't fully recovered the company made
gains in the third quarter adding 2.4
million subscribers so what happened to
the streaming giant this year and how is
it bouncing back
Netflix lost 200 000 subscribers in the
first quarter of 2022 instead of the 2.5
million it projected to gain Netflix
said that completely shutting down its
service in Russia following the
country's attack on Ukraine resulted in
the net loss the company also attributed
the loss to increased subscriber churn
part of that came from a price increase
in January it wasn't the first time that
Netflix had raised prices but it was a
price increase that triggered new sort
of consumer defections along with
increased competition and inflation it
also had to contend with another problem
password sharing these are over 100
million households that already are
choosing to view Netflix they love the
service we just got to get paid you know
at some degree for them so the streamer
moved to make a change we're not trying
to shut down that sharing but we're
going to ask you to pay a bit more to be
able to share and that wasn't all as the
company tried to control costs it laid
off more than 450 people over the next
few months the stock decline triggered a
series of changes that the company is
still enacting so one of the biggest
changes that came after that decline
that was announced that same day was
that Netflix would add an ad supported
tier of service but those changes are an
about face for the streamer which has
famously issued ads and embraced sharing
those who have followed Netflix know
that I've been against the complexity of
advertising and a big fan of the
Simplicity of subscription that
Simplicity worked in the company's favor
at a time when growing was the goal in
the early days of the rise of streaming
and really the streaming Wars what
helped convince consumers to cut their
cable bill was that Netflix was flexible
and you could binge series whenever you
wanted you weren't encumbered with ads
in the same way that you were on cable
and you could share what you paid for
with family and friends and in 2020 that
model really worked especially during
the pandemic the company's vast Content
Library and bingeable series Drew in
customers confined to their homes the
streamer's share price Rose from 319
dollars in March of 2020 to over 550 in
early 2021 it also added a record 37
million new users in 2020. on the
strength of popular shows like the
Queen's Gambit
Tiger King my name is Joe Exotic and
this is Sarge and Bridgerton I wish to
be entertained there's a subset of
companies that benefited intensely from
the pandemic and the way people's lives
changed during it and a commonality that
you see in those companies is that when
times are good it's very hard to imagine
times becoming bad again but things did
get bad as the pandemic wore on and
people started to leave their homes in
2021 the company's growth began to slow
covid created a lot of noise and how to
read the situation you know boosted us a
lot in 2020 and then into 2021 uh I
think we you know thoughtfully said it
was mostly pull forward which was The
Logical conclusion but now coming into
2022 that you know doesn't really hold
April wasn't the first time in 2022 that
Netflix stock sank in January after the
company forecasted slower subscriber
growth shares fell 20 percent in after
hours trading in the streaming business
the number of subscribers that are
paying you to watch your content is
really one of the most important metrics
of a company's Health but while
streaming services like Disney Plus or
HBO Max have other ways of generating
Revenue Netflix almost entirely is in
the business of streaming and so that is
its lifeblood and when it loses
streaming subscribers that is a problem
for the heart of its business and with a
crowded field of streamers gaining new
subscribers can be difficult the
challenge that all the streaming
companies are having now particularly in
the US is they have acquired most of the
customers that are ever going to pay
to stream they have to figure out how to
make more money from those people than
what that puts front and center for all
of these Services is the importance of
competing on content after April's stock
decline the company scrambled to act
quickly there have been Rivals that have
been in the business of selling ad
supported tiers for quite some time
there have been other streaming services
Spotify for one that has always been
very stringent about password sharing so
these are levers that existed before
that Netflix hadn't pulled and so I
think that moment sort of raises the
question of was Netflix too slow to do
all that it could have to avoid the
severity of this moment this year
Netflix's share price is down more than
60 percent but the streamer reported
something of a turnaround in the
September quarter the company added
twice as many subscribers as expected in
Q3 sending shares up in after hours
trading immediately after its report
thank God we're done with shrinking
quarters everything the company's
focused on whether that's on the content
side on marketing lowering prices to the
ad supported the paid sharing the
thoughtful approach we're doing there
lines us up for a good next year looking
ahead the streamer says it's new ad
supported tier will launch in November
for 6.99 a month and the company this
week laid out some of the steps it will
take to crack down on password sharing
and make it easier for subscribers
sharing accounts to make their own those
are the two strategic elements that it
really needs to nail at this point
because those will prove to shareholders
whether or not the the promises and
decisions that Executives have made are
going to bear fruit and set the company
on a more sustainable path in the future
foreign